Well, hey there.
Thank you for being here, especially if
this is your first time with us,
Adventist or otherwise. Grace and peace
to
the body. So, question of the night.
Does Romans 14:1-12
refute
New Testament day keeping?
If not,
what day does it support?
Does Romans 14:1-12 refute New Testament
day keeping?
If not,
what day does it support?
Comment your answer down below in
the comment section.
What's the historical context to what
Paul is addressing in this section of
Romans? Why is food being mentioned in
relation to holy days? What holy days
are actually in focus? That's what we're
going to be discussing tonight and
examining very closely. And with me to
discuss is a friend and guest who has
been with us before, but it has been a
while. Dr. Brant Bosserman has an
exegetical article that is coming out
soon in the Westminster Theological
Journal that is titled The Lord's Day
and the maximalist tendency in Romans
14: 5-6.
Well, Dr. Bosserman was so kind to let
us have a little bit of his time tonight
as well as to give me an early read of
his article, which he is going to be
breaking down into a layman's terms for
us this evening to show how this text
actually supports the universal
Christian practice of first day
corporate worship. But you might be
asking yourself,
who is Dr. Brant Bosserman?
Dr. Bosserman obtained his PhD from
Bangor University, Wales, in philosophy
of religion. His doctoral thesis
centered on the question of how to
distinguish a theological paradox from a
contradiction, interesting subject, and
focuses on the theology and apologetic
of Cornelius Van Til. I'm a big Van Til
guy over here.
His thesis was published under the title
The Trinity and the Vindication of
Christian Paradox in 2014.
In 2012,
Dr. Bosserman was ordained in the
Presbyterian Church in America, that's
my denomination, and commissioned to
plant Trinitas Presbyterian Church in
Woodinville, Washington, where he
continued to serve as minister.
Listeners can follow his teaching
ministry at trinitaschurch.com.
One final matter, if you like what we're
doing here and you want to support us,
consider becoming a channel member,
where you will gain access to our
growing library of members-only content,
including members-only live streams. I
want to thank all of our members. I like
to do this uh as frequently as I can
without belaboring the point. I'm just
so grateful for you guys, even those of
you who are not uh channel members in
the financial sense, but those who pray
for us, some of you both support
financially and through prayers. I
really appreciate you uh and I can't say
that enough. Um many of you send us, you
know, messages, emails. I mean, we get
all sorts of stuff. We have a physical
address that people mail things to. I'm
just so grateful for all of you guys and
grateful for the Lord blessing this
effort. But with that it out of the way,
Dr. Bosserman, thank you for being here,
brother.
What a pleasure. Thanks for having me
again, Miles.
Absolutely. So, I want to start off by
reading Romans 14:
1-12 to make sure everyone knows what
exactly is in focus this evening before
we proceed forward. So, let's do that.
Perfect.
So, it says,
"As for the one who is weak in faith,
welcome him, but not to quarrel over
opinions.
One person believes he may eat anything,
while the weak person eats only
vegetables. Let not the one who eats
despise the one who abstains, and let
not the one who abstains pass judgment
on the one who eats, for God has
welcomed him.
Who are you to pass judgment on the
servant of another?
It is before his own master that he
stands or falls.
And he will be upheld, for the Lord is
able to make him stand.
One person esteems one day as better
than another, while another esteems all
days alike.
Each one should be fully convinced in
his own mind.
The one who observes the day observes it
in honor of the Lord.
The one who eats eats in honor of the
Lord, since he gives thanks to God,
while the one who abstains abstains in
honor of the Lord and gives thanks to
God.
For none of us lives to himself, and
none of us dies to himself.
For if we live, we live to the Lord, and
if we die, we die to the Lord.
So then, whether we live or whether we
die,
we are the Lord's.
For to this end Christ died and lived
again, that he might be Lord both of the
dead and of the living.
Why do you pass judgment on your
brother?
Or you, why do you despise your brother?
For we will all stand before the
judgment seat of God. For it is written,
"As I live, says the Lord, every knee
shall bow to me and every tongue shall
confess to God."
So then, each of us will give an account
of himself to God.
And thus the reading of God's holy word.
So, Brant, this is a staple text in the
discussion of the binding validity of
the Sabbath with multiple parties
appealing here for various reasons. So,
my first question to you,
before we get too far into it,
what are the three standard views when
it comes to what Romans 14:5-6
is talking about?
Yeah, thanks for asking, Miles, because
to really locate my thesis about this
passage and uh the interpretation that
I'll I'll expound on, we really have to
begin with uh what have uh what has been
thought to be the main exegetical
options um by by interpreters really for
centuries. So,
the main options uh go like this. Um
when when it comes to verses 5 and 6 of
the passage, the only two verses dealing
with uh the matter of days and the
keeping of days, um
the predominant position today is what
you might call the uh non-Sabbatarian
reading of the passage. Now, in this in
the non-Sabbatarian reading of the
passage, where it says one person
regards one day above another,
that person that they're talking about
would usually get pegged the weak.
Uh they're those who have a weakness of
conscience, uh kind of a carryover
perhaps from the Old Testament law.
We're thinking of Jewish Christians.
They have a weakness of conscience that
compels them to observe various holy
days. And of course, there's a long list
of those in the Old Covenant scriptures.
And then when it goes on to say that
another person regards every day alike,
it's thought that this is a mature
perspective that um understands that
under the gospel and somehow in in
relation to the teachings of Christ,
there are no holy days whatsoever. There
are just 365 calendar days of the year,
and and the wise or the um the strong,
they understand that
not one day is more significant than
than the next. It may be that the church
has elected to worship on certain days
of the week as opposed to others or to
gather at certain times, but those are
strictly decisions at the disposal of
the church itself, either through its
leadership or or through some other
means. Um this is the non-Sabbatarian
interpretation.
And um again, I would say it is uh
advocated by the vast majority of Bible
interpreters today. Um I'd say in this
particular article that I've written,
I respond perhaps most of all to James
Dunn in the background, who advocates
something akin to this non-Sabbatarian
interpretation. So, we got that stake in
the ground. Does that make enough sense?
Is this something you've heard before, I
imagine, Miles? Absolutely.
Mhm.
Right. And so, next to that, what we'll
call maybe the the dominant view today,
um non-Sabbatarian interpretation, you
have two variations on what you could
call a Sabbatarian interpretation of the
passage. And you know,
you know, relatively recent interpreters
from uh reformed guys like John Murray
to
to a whole list of others in the SDA
camp, you know, historically or the
Seventh Day camp, you know, whether it
be Seventh Day Baptist or other
variations on that sort of thinking, are
going to hold one of two views. Um
It it it all falls under this main
banner.
It's the idea that when Paul says "One
man esteems one day above another and
another man esteems every day alike,"
it's somehow widely understood by
everybody involved that we're only
talking about the larger list of annual
holy days in the Old Testament. It was
understood by all parties in discussion
that the weekly Sabbath, the weekly
hebdomadal yeah, seven, you know, one in
every seven day time of gathering was
beyond the pale of discussion. And um
he's only dealing with a dispute
pertaining to annual and maybe monthly
holy days. And then there's a whole list
of discussions. Is he maybe talking
about people who felt con-
conscience-bound to keep even pagan holy
days, which seems a bit far-fetched to
me. But the idea is this language in
Romans 14:5-6 can be limited to a
discussion of annual holy days. It
doesn't have within the sphere of its
reference the hebdomadal holy day,
once a week holy day that everybody
held in common and never called into
question. And of course, if you are a
first day advocate, it's the first day
of the week that was totally not called
into question. If you're a seventh day
advocate, it's the seventh day that
everybody agreed upon and didn't call
into question.
All right. So, with that as the
backdrop,
my second question.
What is the general thesis of your
article
and what is in focus by Paul
in Romans 14:1-12? All right. So, to get
to my thesis, I'm going to talk about
what I would hope an intuitive listener
would have already arrived at as the
obvious weaknesses of the positions I've
already mentioned.
If you take the non-Sabbatarian reading,
the weaknesses are rather stark.
Uh Paul's entire stated aim in Romans
14, pressing into chapter 15, is to
cultivate unity in Christian worship. He
says at the beginning of Romans 14 in
verse 1, "Now accept the one who is weak
in faith." Now, presumably this
acceptance of the one who is weak in
faith means more than just a disposition
of the heart. The whole point is that
this person who's weak in faith eats
different things than you do, and you're
going to need to accept that person in
some concrete context of meeting
where everything from eating to worship
is going to take place. Look again at
Romans 15:6.
It says that
there Paul says his goal in all of this
these labors of his are so that with one
accord, you may with one voice glorify
the God and Father of our Lord Jesus
Christ. That is to say, he wants this
worshipping body to be able to sing a
doxology together.
And he even goes on to specify that this
doxology needs to be sung by Jews and
Gentiles alike. And specifically, he
goes on in verses 9-12 to quote a
variety of Old Testament passages
prophesying that Jews and Gentiles will
worship together.
And so, the basic problem with the
non-Sabbatarian interpretation is, if
Paul is really saying it's a mark of
strength in maturity in faith that you
don't regard any day as obligatory for
worship or fellowship,
how could he successfully achieve his
stated ends of cultivating a unified
worship assembly? Wouldn't you have some
group of Christians saying, "Nobody can
prevail on me to tell me I need to be
present in a worship service with my
brothers and sisters at any particular
time. I'm going to choose to to worship
with some small enclave of my chosen
friends at, you know, whatever hour of
the day or day of the week that I
choose." And so, the non-Sabbatarian
interpretation has this fundamental
difficulty that it's difficult to
imagine, it's difficult to envisage a
worshipping body having any unity
whatsoever if they cannot agree on the
basic obligation to meet with any
regularity on any specific day or at any
particular time. Does that make enough
sense?
It does. Um
we're going to get into this a little
bit later. Um I know you're focusing
right now on essentially the
non-Sabbatarian position, and we're
going to transition eventually into
talking about how this text actually
does pinpoint a specific day. But, well,
do you have anything else to say before
I move forward? Well, yeah, you know,
I'll I'll talk about the weakness just
briefly of the the two Sabbatarian
positions as I've already described
them. And if you read Dunn's commentary
on Roman Romans, he he he states it
directly. It sounds like a whole lot of
special pleading going on to say that
Paul's sweeping language, "One man
esteems every day alike, um another man
esteems one day above another." It's
difficult to imagine that that sweeping
language could be heard by the Roman
churches to whom he was writing as
having no relevance whatsoever to the
weekly holy day.
Um
uh one man esteems every day alike, it
would strike that he's really talking
about every day without exception. And
it it just it it sounds
well, we could even put it this way.
Paul seems to have had some
understanding that his epistles would be
circulatory. In fact, I mean, in certain
epistles he gives explicit instructions
in that direction. Given that the Roman
epistle is his longest epistle,
it it barely needs the typical sort of
definition of an epistle given its great
size. It's almost impossible to think
that Paul wasn't anticipating that this
Roman epistle would be read far and
wide. And could he have had the
confidence that um when he writes things
like one man esteems every day alike, um
the reader would go, "Oh, that that has
no relevance whatsoever to the weekly
Sabbath." Um it it it just seems
strikingly unlikely that Paul could have
had that sort of an expectation. And so,
with those two critiques in mind, one is
left wanting a better interpretation of
the passage that that doesn't um
suffer the same pitfalls as the standard
interpretations do. And that's kind of
where my reading where
where I take off with those burdens in
the background asking,
"Is there a better way to read the
passage?"
Yeah, and I think something else that's
interesting about this. Now, it doesn't
obviously necessitate, but I think it
supports what you're getting at in your
general thesis. Or rather, it supports
the
you could use this for both Sabbatarian
positions. Romans bro- is broken up into
three general parts. You know, you've
got the sin problem at the beginning.
You've got the solution to that problem.
And then from arguably chapters 10 to 11
through 16, you've got how do I now live
in light of this? And so, it's being
said also in this overarching context of
the essentially the Christian life. And
so, there's something deeper going on
here beyond just
at least in my opinion, um
just general like just general things
about food, general things about holy
days.
Um there's something deeper going on
here.
Well, I'll interject briefly, Miles.
Go ahead. I might say actually, you
know, the salvation question is still
pretty well front and center through
chapter 11. You're working out how the
promises to the sons of God, which are
irrevocable, um you know, in chapter 8,
how they can be true in light of the
temporary apostasy of the people of
Israel. But you're right, from chapter
12 forward, when Paul talks about not
being conformed to this world and talks
about um
this uh
living sacrifice that we are supposed to
be. Uh from that point forward, he he
certainly is dealing with many of the
practical ramifications of this gospel
that he's been expounding. But I wanted
to at least get that structural piece
out.
Yeah, you're you're right. I got the I
got the chapters wrong on that. But the
the general idea of these these three
parts, and and this is falling in this
category of how shall we now live. In
the title of the paper, you use the term
and you've you've mentioned it here a
couple times, maximalist. Mhm. And I I
think the general reader of scripture,
the general Christian might be thinking,
"Hmm, I heard you kind of explain that
to some degree,
um and you use this term to contrast
throughout the paper the minimalist
interpretation." So, for the sake of the
audience,
what is the difference between a
minimalist
and a maximalist view
of Romans 14:5-6?
Yes. And I'm going to just re- rephrase
the question a little bit because
minimalist and maximalist, those two
of the passage. They interpret they they
refer to the two different perspectives
being represented in the passage as uh
in in my estimation, strong and weak
respectively. And I'll go ahead and
explain it's my basic thesis, and then
that that'll get us into maximalism and
minimalism.
In contrast to both of the the
broad views represented from the
beginning, one Sabbatarian to
non-Sabbatarian,
um I argue that what's going on in the
passage when you read in Romans 14:5,
"One man esteems one day above another."
There is a
an implicit parameter on the days that
we're talking about throughout the
passage. It's that one person esteems
one holy day above another holy day.
Another person attempts to esteem or to
keep every holy day.
Now, when you read the passage this way,
we no longer have to fall into the
pitfalls of the two opposing positions
that we've discussed earlier. And I'll
explain why, but on the reading that I'm
providing, the person who esteems one
holy day above another is a minimalist.
He recognizes that there's something
that Christ has done that means I'm no
longer obliged to keep the obligated to
keep the entire system of Old Testament
holy days.
Um I have an insight that provides me
with a clear conscience in in keeping a
much much smaller set, and as we'll see
in the course of this argument, just one
holy day of them all.
Um in this case, the man in 14:5a
corresponds to the man in 14:2a.
Uh the same person has the faith that he
can eat all things. He has a much
smaller sense of his dietary obligations
than a person worshipping in the old
covenant. Note that I said smaller
because it's a presupposition of all in
all of Paul Paul's writings that um
believers Christians would uh
celebrate the Lord's Supper. So, it's
not as though these minimalists have no
holy meals. They just got one now. It's
the Lord's Supper and then they can eat
everything else. They don't have any
dietary prohibitions. And they have this
understanding in light of the faith they
have in Christ, says Paul. So, the
minimalist has this idea that our
dietary obligations and our obligations
as regards holy days
are significantly lesser than in the Old
Testament. The maximalist by contrast
would be a person who's attempting to
keep every holy day.
I'll make the point in the course of my
argument that that encompasses the
Lord's Day um
that they would gather on that day um
with other believers and yet still want
to be keeping the various festivals of
the Old Testament and also uh a Sabbath
rest on on the seventh day of the week.
This same group also has this
understanding that they can only eat
vegetables according to 14:2 uh
presumably keeping the Mosaic uh
proscriptions
against eating uh meats sacrificed to
idols and in that respect uh meats that
are tainted by by pagan worship. So, if
we read the passage this way uh we're
going to arrive at you know very
different conclusions about um
you know if when we parse out verses 5
and 6 exactly who's being referenced in
each of the phrases that follow. But
also uh we'll see in the course of time
we avoid all the pitfalls of the
previously uh described views.
That's good, man. Um
I I want to look at something you say in
the article before I ask my next
question. Now that people kind of
understand what you mean between these
two different um viewpoints.
This is from page 18 of the article. I
don't know what it will be when it's in
the journal, but page 18 of what you
sent me you write
quote does the literary and historical
context of Romans 14 1 through 15:13
everywhere presuppose that Christians
were united in observing some regular
days of assembly? If so
then the non-Sabbatarian understanding
of 14:5B
that a strong party denied the unique
significance of any day cannot be
substantiated
and a more plausible understanding of
the strong position must be sought. At
the same time
if Romans 14:5 is couched in a literary
and historical context that was
preoccupied with matters germane to holy
days then the most plausible alternative
to the non-Sabbatarian reading
is one which qualifies all the days
under discussion
and not just the first reference to a
day in 14:5A
as holy.
Close quote. So, my question for you
what is the strongest argument for why
Romans 14 is not disparaging the idea
of there being a new covenant holy day?
Okay.
So,
let me see here.
I'm going to start by by commenting on
on the first observation you made that
the the point that the Pauline epistles
in Romans in particular everywhere
presupposes that there's a regular day
of worship. Do you mind if I I jump in
there first before we get to that next
question? Absolutely. All right. So, the
way the book opens the way Romans opens
is Paul frankly stating his desire to
come and visit these Roman churches his
desire to impart a spiritual gift of
some sort whether it be himself
preaching or you know something more
along the lines perhaps of his
anticipation that others would manifest
spiritual gifts at his coming.
Um he is anticipating going to a place
where there is some sort of regular
gathering where he could expect to be in
such fellowship with people. He writes
later
about a desire or an appetite to be
refreshed in their company.
Um all that he writes in chapter 12
about a church that has those who exhort
those who rule those who exercise
generosity and a variety of other gifts
these things all presuppose that the
Romans are gathering sufficiently
regularly so that when Paul arrives it's
not as if there's going to be some
makeshift celebration uh that is put
together out of the pure liberty of
saints' hearts to gather at the same
time happenstantially.
Um it all presupposes that there is
regular worship is going on and um Paul
can come and participate in that. That
it's marked by regular preaching that
it's marked by regular meals. All of
this speaks to the fact that
there isn't a party in among the Romans
who's saying no no every day is exactly
the same as any other day and um you
know all all that we have are these
impromptu gatherings as Christians. Um
it's it's it's implausible in the nature
of the case.
But before we get to the question that
you had asked subsequently as to you
know what the strongest argument there
is
to make that in Romans Paul actually has
um
you know a specific holy day in mind I
think we do need to take some of the
hard steps toward why I would advance
the particular thesis that I do um about
the maximalist and minimalist
assignments and positions as I've
described them.
And if you don't mind I'd like to just
talk a little bit about the structure of
Romans 14 if that's okay. The floor is
yours.
Absolutely.
Well, the first stake in in my argument
is actually one that I was delighted to
discover in the course of developing my
own thoughts really very near the end of
it. Another interpreter who's actually a
7-day interpreter Norman Young um
actually came to the same observations
about structure that I had in the course
of my reading. And of course I
discovered the antecedents to both of
our thinking in um
everyone from uh DeLacy to uh even back
of that John Murray and a fellow
not so many folks know these days, but a
guy named Francis Nigel Lee made similar
observations. And here are the
observations that that I want to set
before any interested interpreter. Um
all throughout Romans 14
Paul has a habit of describing
the strong position on matters of diet
and days first and the weak position on
diet and days second. So, you open it up
and you just read Romans 14 verse 1.
Says now accept the one who is weak in
faith. So, there are those who are weak.
And and later in Romans 15:1 Paul's
going to say we who are strong
identifying himself with the strong
party. It says in 14:1 accept the one
who is weak in faith, but not for the
purpose of passing judgment on his
opinions. What acceptance are we talking
about? Apparently accept him into
fellowship both at worship in these
worshipful meals that believers have
together. Look at 14:2 and ask yourself
who's mentioned first the strong or the
weak. It says the one who has faith
is evidently mature. The one who has
faith that he may eat one person has
faith that he may eat all things, but he
who is weak eats vegetables only.
Apparently the first person is the
individual
who has an enlightened understanding
that he is no longer bound by dietary
restrictions
of the law and the other person has this
sense that he is bound by those
restrictions. Why to only vegetables?
Well, because most of the meat in the
ancient world would have been sacrificed
to idols and therefore arguably tainted
from the perspective of the Mosaic Law.
But it's very clear the strong person is
mentioned first the weak is mentioned
second. As you go on in verses 3 and 4
the one who eats again the strong is not
to regard with contempt the one who does
not eat and the one who does not eat is
not to judge with judge the one who
eats. Again, you have the strong and the
weak mentioned in that order. And the
same thing is observed all the way down
to the end of the passage and again it's
actually Young is is the first
interpreter that I've come across who
takes it as far as to the end of Romans
14 uh where it says you know the faith
which you have you know here referring
to the strong um have as your own
conviction before God. Happy it is is he
who does not condemn himself in what he
approves, but he who doubts that's again
the weak. Again strong weak mentioned
again and again. Well, if you follow
that pattern that would lead you to the
conclusion that in Romans 14:5 a very
different set of associations than what
you have in the standard non-Sabbatarian
interpretation must be embraced. When it
says in verse 5 that one person
regards one day above another it is a
mistake to view that as the weak
individual. The pattern of the passage
is that that must be the strong
individual.
And then another regards every day alike
must actually be the weak individual.
So, this is the first observation, the
structural pattern that would compel you
to make different associations in the
passage than what you find among the
non-Sabbatarian interpreters. But, if
you left it right there, the weak
position would seem to be virtually
incomprehensible.
Verse two tells us that the weak the
weak man feels himself bound by the
dietary restrictions of the Old
Testament, compelling him to only eat
vegetables. But, then the weak of verse
five
is someone who esteems all days alike,
apparently has a libertine view of days.
There are no binding days any longer.
And that would be an incomprehensible
position for someone to take. So, the
next step toward the interpretation I'm
advancing involves recognizing something
that very, very few English translations
convey. In fact, is is this the ESV that
you've got on the screen, Miles?
That is correct.
Right.
Well, the ESV reading
I I would argue makes this mistake as
well.
The word every that you find after the
word after the statement another esteems
all days, excuse me, or rather alike.
That word is not there in the Greek
text.
The word alike is an interpolation
that a translators to the best of their
ability trying to make sense of Paul in
certain into that passage. And it's
understandable why they do. They're
trying to ask the question, how do you
have a contrast as the grammar requires
between a person who esteems one day as
better than another
and another person who esteems every
day. Wherein lies the contrast?
And
you can you can gather why a translator
would say that it must be that the the
second person has kind of an equalizing
view of all days.
Whereas the other one esteems them
differently, one better than the other.
But again, the word alike is not there.
And I would simply point out that the
the authority
uh when it comes to uh
you know, uh
when it comes
BDAG is what they call the the lexicon.
Yeah, BDAG. BDAG is exactly Bauer's, you
know, expanded, you know, all the way
through um
Donker and you know, these other
other lexicographers, if you will.
They don't in their lexicon suggest that
Romans 14:5-6,
or rather verse five, needs that word
alike in there.
You
It is perfectly natural to translate the
passage one person esteems one day as
better than another, while another
esteems every day.
And once you embrace that
interpretation, rather than posit an
implicit adverb alike,
the more natural thing to do is to posit
a an implicit parameter.
One person esteems one holy day as
better than another holy day.
While another esteems all holy days.
Once you read the passage like that, you
have two perfectly intelligible
positions to contrast.
Again, the maxima the maximalist, the
weak individual mentioned second in 14:2
and 14:5, he's the individual who feels
himself bound by Mosaic dietary
pris- dietary laws and also obliged to
keep uh Mosaic holy days.
Um all of them, the full gamut. But,
there's this other individual, the
strong, who is no longer under the
burden of Mosaic Mosaic dietary laws and
also has a much more selective view of
days. That's the individual we're
calling the minimalist. It's clear in
the Pauline epistles that people are
gathering and worshiping on a regular
basis.
And um
these two groups can coexist and carry
on as Paul says, both fully convinced in
their own mind for one very important
reason.
The minimalist and the maximalist, if
you were to draw two circles as in a
Venn diagram, and you were to list the
days that they both observed, there
would be a sliver in the middle
of a day or days at this point. I'll
leave it open at this point in our
discussion. There'd be a sliver in the
middle where minimalist and maximalist
are agreed.
I'm going to argue in the course of our
discussion as I do in the argu- as I do
in the article, that that day is the
Lord's Day.
But, the point is this is a much more
satisfactory reading of the passage than
the two standard positions.
You don't have any group saying we don't
have to worship on any day. Uh no,
you've got the minimalist who who has a
a small set of days that they believe
they need to worship on.
You have the maximalist who's trying to
keep a variety of days, but they can
both carry on fully convinced in their
own mind and sing a doxology together
because their convictions center
on at least one day together.
And we'll see in the course of our
discussion as well, Paul seems to be
arguing something similar about diet.
It's precisely because their convictions
both agree on the Lord's Supper that
they can get past whatever differences
they might have when it comes to
additional dietary restrictions or
obligations.
You know, it's interesting you bring up
that some things can often times be lost
in translation, if you will, to the
English. Um I don't want to sidetrack us
here, but just out of curiosity, I'm
curious if you know. So, for example,
Matthew 28:1, uh 1 through 10
technically. Um in Luther's translation,
Miles Coverdale, the Vulgate, you've got
a number of translations there that for
example, in the English you lose um in
the Greek you've actually got the phrase
first day Sabbath.
Um why is it that you think in English
translations we lose some of these
things? Cuz you're saying here in Romans
14, there's something here that we seem
to kind of lose that when you actually
parse out the Greek, um it is a lot
clearer than what we see for example in
the ESV. Why is that?
Well, I mean, the short answer is that I
mean, but that there are two reasons. I
mean, there is there's just the reality
that that there is no such thing as a
simple straight-across translation. So,
you're always going to be dealing with
the fact that you you know, you you just
mentioned in you know, Matthew 28:1,
you know, the word Sabbath in in Greek
is functions it has a double function.
It can mean week or the seventh day of
the week. So, it can mean the seven days
or the seventh day.
We don't have an equivalent word like
that in English, do we, Miles? We don't
have a word that means both Sabbath and
week. And I'm actually going to go into
you know, it's going to come to bear as
to why I don't think Paul mentions the
first day of the week. He doesn't want
to say the word Sabbath in this passage.
And I'll talk about why in a little bit.
That's the first thing. There's no
simple linguistic translation that can
take place. And there's also the
distance of context. You know, the
historical context that comes to bear
and renders these things difficult for
us as well. That also plays into the
matter. But, those two observations do
bring us back to the question that you
had asked about um you know, if you
could put up the last question you had,
what is the strongest argument for why
Romans 14 is not disparaging the idea of
there being a new covenant holy day?
Well, let's go into that.
So, we already saw that
the preponderance of of of evidence
would have us believing that Christians
had a regular time of worship that could
only be understood as a holy day if it
was the recurring um
time of assembly and where where all of
these things from preaching to the
Lord's Supper and other ordinances of
the church would come about. Um
the question we have to ask ourselves at
this point is
what were the widely recognized group of
holy days that maximalist would have
been keeping or attempting to keep in
their entirety and minimalist would
select from and say there is a smaller
set or even an individual day alone
that's obligatory for us. And so,
to answer that question, uh the first
thing I want to just observe is this.
You have this pattern in Jewish history
extending out of the Old Testament into
the intertestamental period
that when
utterly remarkable works of God occur in
history, it requires the commemoration
of a day. So, we begin with you know,
the most monumental work of creation,
right? Um
That is the basis of the the seventh day
Sabbath. Um you know, all throughout the
Old Testament, of course, in the
Decalogue it's set forth that way.
But, of course, you have these other
days. You have the Passover, which
initially was that transition evening um
in the month of Nisan in the spring from
the 14th to the 15th, where the Jewish
uh firstborns were were spared if they
were in the house that was covered by
blood. And the Egyptian firstborns were
not. Um and what does that result in? It
results in an annual holiday at the
beginning of
Israel's uh uh the their religious
calendar every year. It begins with this
holy day. And you go throughout the Old
Testament, what do you see? You see the
Feast of Purim
um there in Esther established because
of the incredible miraculous deliverance
of the people of Israel. So, you have
this pattern starting in scripture,
extending through uh in you know, of
course, the intertestamental literature
and what what we now have as Hanukkah
established in that time period. And we
even have days in the Jewish calendar um
in the 1st century that many of us have
frankly even forgotten. I think of Yom
Nicanor when Judas Maccabeus delivers
the the people
from, you know, the invasions of Nicanor
who is
the
leader of an army that employs elephants
in its midst. Um
this
concept that big things, mighty acts of
God, and especially mighty deliverance
from God necessitates
some sort of commemoration.
When you take that into the New
Testament period and that mentality
still clearly exists. We read in the New
Testament about Pharisees who are
excited that they fast, you know, twice
a week or
you know, there are these extra-biblical
traditions of celebration that they are
eager to keep.
When the gospel itself entails
proclaiming that the eternal Son of God
has been risen from the dead
on the first day of the week,
it is impossible to imagine a Jewish
mind going, "And that has no bearing
whatsoever on our holy days."
This most monumental thing in human
history up to this point as it's
understood by the apostles and all their
listeners, this
intrusion of the resurrection into human
history that everybody expected at the
end of human history, there is no way
that a Jewish mind would not intuitively
go, "That marks a new holy day."
And of course when you add to that the
pattern of Jesus appearing and
expounding the law on the first day,
first to the disciples on on the road to
Emmaus, then to the rest of the
disciples in the evening, the next
first day after that, eight days later
him appearing again to the disciples,
and then 50 days after that, Peter
preaching the first great Christian
sermon to the baptism of thousands after
that.
When you see this pattern of worship and
worshipful acts on a day that was marked
out with such singular significance by
the resurrection,
uh
I would argue there is no possible way
that the early church would not regard
the first day of the week as a
hebdomadal holy day obligatory for acts
of worship. And of course what do you
see from Paul but him requiring the
gathering of offerings on the first day
of of the week which was an act germane
to Old Testament holy days,
the tithe being brought in whether it be
in booths or other other times of the
year.
It's widely understood that that's when
the tithe would have been brought in or
at least
one of the expressions of the tithe in
the Old Testament. Paul of course again
in Acts chapter 20 expounding the word
and breaking bread with disciples on the
first day. And of course it's the the
best explanation for the phrase the
Lord's Day in Revelation. So with with
those points in mind,
the idea that the list of holy days, of
which some are attempting to keep every
one of them, others understand that they
can heed one day above another, the idea
that it would encompass the Lord's Day
or the first day of the week,
I think the arguments are very strong
for that conclusion.
And I'll stop there before I pass on the
main argument to that conclusion in this
this article.
Are those ideas you're familiar with,
Miles?
Absolutely, and there's there's
something you said there though that
just I had my mic was muted so you
didn't hear me go ah audibly.
That just it just
adds to the pile of things that just it
makes so much sense. And it's
essentially what you alluded to that
monumental things are memorialized by
something. Mhm.
The Lord's Supper memorializes
something. That this monumental thing
that our Lord, you know, I get choked up
even thinking about it. When I approach
the Lord's table, you know, I I often
have tears in my eyes.
And I'm not trying to be sensational
when I say that I I genuinely mean that.
It's the table of Thanksgiving and I
always under my breath quietly say to
myself, "Thank you, my Lord, for what
you're giving me, yourself, and what I'm
about to receive, which is you."
And there's something you said there
that
um I want to read a quote if you don't
mind from Thomas Watson from his book
The The Ten Commandments where he is
essentially essentially expounding upon
the cataclysmical use of the Ten
Commandments, but he talks about in the
Fourth Commandment the same thing that
you just said about, "Is it not logical
to think that
the resurrection day, which is this
monumental change in all of creation, in
all of existence, I mean, our calendar
is marked by 2024 from what?
2024 from what? What are what are we
what are we saying 2024 from?
Well, I want to read a quote here. I
read this quite frequently on this
platform and I just
the way he words this and shows it is
just perfectly it expounds upon exactly
what it was that you were saying and he
says, "Quote,
Now, there's a grand reason for changing
of the Jewish Sabbath to the Lord's Day.
Now, Adventists hear Jewish Sabbath and
they often times think of what a lot of
modern say dispensational thinkers are
saying and I know Watson is not meaning
that same thing. He's simply referring
to a landmark when he uses that term, a
certain period of time. He's obviously
not saying that the Sabbath was only
relegated to Moses. I just want to
clarify that for the Adventists in the
audience, but he says, "Now, there's a
grand reason for changing of the Jewish
Sabbath to the Lord's Day because this
puts us in mind of the mystery of our
redemption by Christ. The reason why God
did institute the old Sabbath was
because God would have it kept as a
memorial of the creation,
a monumental act.
Because God would have it kept as a
memorial of the creation, but the Lord
hath now brought the first day of the
week in the room of it in memory of a
more glorious work than creation.
And that is redemption.
Great was the work of creation, but
greater was the work of redemption. This
is essentially Watson recognizing that
Exodus 20 roots the Sabbath in creation,
but then the second giving of the law in
Deuteronomy 5:15 essentially roots it in
redemption.
Yes.
Great was the work of creation, but
greater was the work of redemption.
As it was said in Haggai 2:9, "The glory
of the second temple was greater than
the glory of the first temple. So the
glory of the redemption was greater than
the glory of the creation. Great wisdom
was seen in the curious making of us,
but more miraculous wisdom in saving
us." Yes.
"Great power was seen in bringing us out
of nothing, but greater power in helping
us when we were worse than nothing."
This is Watson essentially bringing out
a common motif. Calvin brought this out
a lot obviously regarding the lesser to
the greater. He continues, "It cost more
to redeem us than to create us."
And now he explains why. "In the
creation, there was but speaking a word,
Psalm 148:5.
In the redeeming of us, there was the
shedding of blood, 1 Peter 1:19.
The creation was the work of God's
fingers, Psalm 8:3.
Redemption was the work of his arm, Luke
1:5.
In the creation,
God gave us ourselves.
In the redemption, he gave us himself.
By creation, we have a life in Adam.
By redemption, we have a life in Christ,
Colossians 3:3.
By creation, we had a right to an
earthly paradise. By redemption, we have
a title to a heavenly kingdom.
So that while Christ might change the
seventh day of the week into the first
because this day puts us in mind of our
redemption, which is a more glorious
work than the creation. Close quote."
I think that perfectly perfectly just
I love Thomas Watson. I know lots of
people are not fans of the Puritans. I
am. I have Owen's Hebrews commentary set
behind me. I just
his his explanation there of the lesser
to the greater is just so
he goes on further in in the book to
talk about just more examples of the
lesser to the greater and that perfectly
synchronizes with what you just said
about the fact that
all monumental cataclysmical changing
things are always memorialized by
something and we have something in the
new covenant that that fits that bill
essentially.
That's right. That's right. And you know
what? I would even add Watson's
observations. How true are they to the
opening of the Roman epistle? Paul
doesn't begin by saying the good news of
this God who's created you. Fact from
verses 18 and following, he says it's
actually dangerous news about this God
who created you, who's invisible
attributes have been clearly seen, but
men have only suppressed them. The work
of creation, unfortunately, against
the backdrop of a sinful humanity,
um that work of creation is not good
news for us. And what he does open his
letter talking about therefore is not
the work of creation. He opens his
letter talking about the monumental work
of Jesus Christ in the gospel, who
uh consi- you know,
he says it this way. He describes
himself as an apostle,
set apart for the gospel of God.
And this gospel he promised beforehand
through his prophets in the holy
scriptures concerning his son, who is
born of a descendant of David according
to the flesh, who was declared the son
of God with power by the resurrection
from the dead according to the spirit
spirit of holiness, Jesus Christ our
Lord. He He says the good news of the
gospel is this monumental event. It's
the thing I've got to open with. It's
the thing that I want to talk about,
that I'm going to expound. It's the
thing that this entire concept of the
church is based on.
This son of God become son of David,
declared son of God with power by the
resurrection from the dead. All of this
speaks to the same conclusion, that in
the new covenant our obsession, you
could say, uh as for things to be
remembered, centers on the resurrection
of Christ, the begin- beginning of the
new creation,
um or as Paul will say in 2 Corinthians,
the ground on the basis of which all the
all things are being made new.
So,
we've come to the point then
that
the first day is among the holy days, a
recognizable holy days that would be
under discussion in Romans 14:5-6.
This means that we're not falling into
the error of um Sabbatarian interpreters
who by special pleading say that
the one hebdomadal holy day, the one
special um
weekly holy day is out of the discussion
here. We're actually going to make the
argument that it's front and center here
in this discussion. And I just want to
make one more argument for why we would
conclude that the first day
is among the holy days
uh
that that people would have recognized
in the first century
in in Jewish and Christian communities.
And
it's it's this argument here.
The best explanation for why you even
have a dispute between maximalists and
minimalists in the New Testament that we
have evidence for in a variety of
places. Colossians 2:16, Hebrews I was
just going to say Galatians chapter 4
verse 10.
Um
you have this discussion that some
people are wanting to keep all of the
Jewish holy days. Evidently, others have
a sense of liberation from them.
It's very difficult to explain how these
two camps would arise among Christians
unless you posit the establishment of a
new holy day on the first day of the
week. Here's what I mean.
If the apostles had been out preaching
as central to their message that holy
days have ceased to exist or they have
just been significantly reduced,
it's difficult to understand how someone
under their tutelage would come to the
conclusion, "No, no, apostles. In fact,
we have to keep them all."
Uh just the same if the apostles were
busy teaching uh even something to the
effect of only the seventh day needs to
be kept um as opposed to no days need to
be kept, again, how you get the opposite
view arising that some were saying, you
know, uh
uh in fact, we have to keep every day.
It's It's It's hard
It's hard to piece that together or to
make sense of that.
On the other hand,
if the apostolic message centered on the
resurrection of Jesus Christ on the
first day of the week as all four
gospels tell us that occurred.
And that message, that proclamation
began on the first day of the week when
God the Holy Spirit was poured out in
abundance so that sons and daughters
would prophesy.
And this message centered on the first
day of the week, heralded on the first
day of the week, carried with it front
and center the concept that now the
first day is a holy day.
We have the best explanation for how you
get both minimalists and maximalists.
Minimalists who have strong faith
understand this is the holy day that
summarizes and fulfills them all. Why?
Because it's an anticipation of eternity
itself wherein the resurrection will be
realized for all of the saints, and it
is especially focused and centered in
Christ himself.
They had this insight that that holy day
would be a holy day which, again, uh
subsumes and takes precedence over them
all and even renders it so that all
prior holy days
fall short of the function of this one.
That, we would argue, would be a
reasonable conclusion, a mature
perspective.
Uh
on the other hand, you can understand
how this proclamation of resurrection on
the first day and carrying with it a new
day of commemoration, people might go,
"Oh,
well, the Lord is really into days. He's
been into days uh all throughout the
Mosaic covenant and for a long time."
And so what this means is that we ought
to continue keeping all of the other
holy days along with this one of central
significance now.
Um and that would be the faithful way to
take a lesson from the new establishment
of the first day.
Uh it's intelligible, again, on the
establishment of the first day with the
apostolic preaching, therefore, why you
would get both maximalist and minimalist
positions.
It's not so intelligible why you would
get those positions on any of the other
views being advanced, the three standard
views that we've been discussing.
Any questions about that?
No. Um but I do want to transition to
the next question, which kind of
piggybacks off of that.
Miles, I hate to do this. No, go ahead.
came to mind. But one of the proofs that
I I I would want to throw out there for
why this perspective on holy days is so
important, this minimalist-maximalist
perspective that arise from the
establishment of something new. The
reason why it's so compelling is that it
has a profound parallel with two other
like instances in the New Testament.
What am I referring to? I'm referring to
the initiatory sign of the covenant in
the case of baptism, which, again, what
do we have the apostles preaching? Are
they simply preaching circumcision is
gone?
That's not the only thing they're
preaching. They're preaching that the
initiatory right, and in fact, the one
baptism that we have in the New
Testament, in contrast to the multitude
of baptisms that we have in the old, all
the washings and cleansings, and
frankly, circumcision is a sort of right
of cleansing as well. All of these
rights of cleansing, say the apostles,
have been superseded by one faith, one
baptism, Ephesians 4.
Um as opposed to a multiplicity of them.
Here we have an instance where the
establishment of a new right,
the mature will understand that what it
does is it supersedes and it
discontinues all the previous rights of
initiation and rights of cleansing.
Um and yet, you had a party who took a
maximalist perspective, "Well, God is
clearly in the cleansing. We've got a
big Christian baptism now. What that
means is we have to carry on and persist
in all these former rights of
cleansing." You can understand how both
perspectives arose with the
establishment of a new ordinance in a
way that's far more difficult to explain
if you could have could have imagined
the apostles only preaching, "Don't get
circumcised." Um as opposed to, you
know, what they were preaching,
"Baptism is this new right." And the
other parallel that I would set out
there as well is the Lord's Supper. No
one disputes uh in this
debate about days that the Lord's Supper
was a New Testament obligatory right for
Christians.
Well,
think again about the parallel. You had
people saying, "Oh, yes, of course we
have to keep the Lord's Supper." Um and
that
makes me think if I'm a maximalist,
God's saying, "You know, I've always
been into meals. I've always been into
foods that you should or shouldn't eat.
The Lord's
Whereas what we're going to argue in the
course of things here is that the
minimalists rightly understood this is
the one right, the one meal of Christian
fellowship that is is
an obligation for Christians and needs
to be guarded and protected. We can even
get along with people who who maybe are
whose conscience tell them they need to
keep other dietary burdens, but
the point is made again, it's the
establishment of a new right
of circumcision,
of uh excuse me, of baptism, of the
Lord's Supper, and a new day, which best
explains the rise of both minimalist and
maximalist perspectives in the New
Testament era. Thank you for for letting
me get that in there, but I think it's a
pretty powerful par- parallel to
observe.
No, definitely, and I I've talked about
that a lot on this platform. Um and just
to kind of reiterate there for the
audience, um
you're kind of just laying out the
logical conclusion of there being
a new covenant form of the Passover,
which is the Lord's Supper, a new
covenant form of circumcision, which is
baptism, Colossians 2.
There's also a new covenant form of the
seventh-day Sabbath, Mhm. the first-day
Sabbath. That's right.
You've got these three things that are
essentially as uh to use the words of
Dr. Philip Schaff in his History of the
Christian Religion, these are old
covenant uh forms baptized by the work
of redemption through Christ, brought in
as a new covenant forms. But I have a
question
I know I keep stopping you with these
questions.
No, of course. Go for it.
And I love how you phrased that, and it
was well said, but I'm just going to
make sure we get this additional
observation and and caveat in there. You
would be right to say that baptism
replaces circumcision, and right to say
the Lord's Supper replaces Passover, and
right to say that this that the first
day replaces the seventh.
But key to what I'm saying here is that
baptism replaces not just circumcision,
but it replaces every washing that a
leper would undergo after cleansing.
That a person who had touched a dead
body would undergo after that
contact, which would keep him from from
the tabernacle. It it's replacing even
the right of marrying a foreign bride,
where she would have to cut all of her
hair and her nails to have a right of
discontinuity with the past and being
made new, coming into this new place. It
replaces all of those things. It's even
one of the reasons why when people, you
know, freak out about, you know, our
arguments for for paedo-baptism, and we
say it replaces, you know, circumcision,
well, then why do Well, why do you
baptize girls, you know, because that
was just for boys. Well, there were
other rites of cleansing that only
pertain to women that baptism replaces,
such as the the the the rites for of
cleansing for for her monthly period.
And so,
I'm saying that it's replacing all of
those things, and it helps to explain
why there's this minimalist and
maximalist tendency. It is this release
from a
rather huge litany of things that you
would have to do. It's why it's a
powerful statement that there's one
Lord, one faith, one baptism. Same is
true of the Lord's Supper, replaces
surely the Passover, but how many
sacrificial meals did you have in the
Old Testament prescribed in the various,
you know, types of, you know, shalom
offering, votive offering, things like
that, where one would go to the temple
and eat a meal in the presence of the
Lord with a priest. It's replacing all
of those things. Or even the priest Or
even the priest having to eat the the
the the meal the the the offering.
That's right. Even the priest's
activity, because we're this priesthood
of believers.
And and of course, what we're getting at
as well is with the Lord's Day, it is
not just a replacement of the
seventh-day Sabbath,
and it would be an error to to think of
it that way. It is the summation of
Israel's holy days. And it is this this
this grand point of Christian worship
and celebration. Um you know, it
encompasses, therefore,
and supersedes every weekly, monthly,
annual holy day. Um because precisely it
it's it's the day that is is marked by
Christ's resurrection, his you could
say, you know, inauguration of eternity
in the present. And and
it's that attachment there that means
that it supersedes all that that
precedes it, and it it releases um from
obligation to that longer list of holy
days. So, I hope that point is is you
know,
is appreciated as I continually put off
this next question that you have.
Well, now I'm going to I'm I'm like
fired up to go study this more, because
you're saying so many things here. I'm
having a bunch of lightbulb moments,
that's why I'm kind of like going, ah,
wow, oh.
Um it's like a summation of all of these
washings, all of these eatings, all of
these days
into uh into this one grander thing. So,
um
thank you thank you for that. Um
I I I don't want to I don't want to
sidetrack us here, because there's so
many other things that I want to say on
that, cuz again, I'm so many things are
are like coming up in my mind now. Um
but with the question I keep putting
off,
I just want to reiterate this
or have you reiterate this for people in
the audience that that they say, "Brant,
I'm hearing everything you're saying
here. Okay, I I I get that. I'm
following your train of thinking." Maybe
they aren't following that. Regardless,
they're still saying, "But doesn't
Romans 14:5
plainly say that one person esteems one
day above another, and one esteems every
day alike? Doesn't that clearly prove
the non-Sabbatarian interpretation?"
Right. Yeah, so to just reiterate and to
jump two feet back into the exegesis of
the passage, cuz we want to get to verse
six.
No, it it definitely doesn't clearly
state that, and it's going to that point
is going to hinge on the observation
that the word alike, which you find in
so many English translations or some
variation of that adverb, is not in the
Greek text. It's it's a translator's
best effort at trying to create a
contrast between 14:5a and 14:5b. But to
reiterate our position, 14:5a,
one person regards one day above
another, ought to be read with an
implicit parameter on the types of days
in view. One day One person regards one
holy day above another holy day. They
have a strong perspective
guided by faith in Christ and deep
understanding of faith in Christ that
allows them to make this evaluation that
I don't have to heed every holy day. I
can esteem one holy day above another,
maybe all the others, and I'll argue
it's exactly that that they do.
Um whereas another individual says in
14:5b,
another regards every day
every holy day. Not every day alike, as
if every 365 days of the year is the
they have the same status to the
individual, but rather they regard every
holy day as equally binding on them,
whether a holy day established in the
new covenant or in the old covenant. And
that's the contrast that we have there.
I suppose the natural question that
anyone would have as I'm advancing this
thesis is
exactly how selective were the strong?
How many holy days did they did they
heed? And specifically, which one was
it?
And this is where um
14:6,
I think
takes us a a long way in in answering
that that question, and gives us a very
strong reason for concluding that the
strong only regard one day of the full
gamut of potential holy days as an
obligation for Christians. Okay?
So, to advance that thesis, look look at
how verse six begins. Miles, why don't
you maybe read that for me as I just
grab something on my notes.
Yeah, so verse Romans 14:6, it says,
"The one who observes the day observes
it in honor of the Lord.
The one who eats eats in honor of the
Lord, since he gives thanks to God,
while the one who abstains
abstains in honor of the Lord, and gives
thanks to God." Excellent. So, here,
look at what we have. First of all, it
says, "One person" Now, note, this is
the person mentioned first. We've noted
the pattern that the strong, or the
minimalist, consistently is mentioned
first, so we would expect this to be the
strong party who esteems one day above
another. It's the same person who
observes the day.
He observes He who observes the day
observes it for the Lord. Well, note, to
begin with, there's a definite article
there in Greek. It's the day that the
strong person observes. Now, if Paul had
wanted to to paint the picture of a man
who is keeping multiple holy days, the
more natural way to do that would have
been he who observes a day observes it
to the Lord, any one of those days. It
would make more sense for
hemera to be an after us, to not have a
specific, you know,
any specifying force imparted by the
article. So, that's the first thing. It
would also have created a more
Um but he doesn't do that. Uses the
definite article. And so, in that
respect, we follow one contemporary
interpreter,
a fellow by the last name of of Wisse.
He's a German interpreter, who also
argues that a specific day is in view
here.
Um
And once we have that concept that a
specific day is in view, clearly Paul
wants to gather with the church,
presumably on some regular week day.
So, what day would that be?
And once we ask that question, we have
at least seven reasons to conclude that
the day referenced in 14:6a
is the Lord's Day, or the first day of
the week. Um the first is that it's the
only one that naturally parallels with
the description of the strong in 14:2,
as those who know they're allowed to eat
anything. They're not any longer under
any Mosaic dietary restriction. Well,
what day would correspond with this
correct, strong, faithful understanding
that they're no longer bound by Mosaic
Mosaic dietary descriptions? The most
natural answer would be a new day
established in the new covenant, which
means that you are no longer bound by
the Old Testament Sabbaths, weekly,
monthly, or annual.
Um So, do you see the logic there? Would
it make much sense for there to be a
party who's saying, "We know ourselves
to not be bound by Mosaic dietary
restrictions, but we are totally bound
by the seventh-day Sabbath"? Or does it
make more sense for the group who is
free from dietary restrictions in the
Old Testament to understand that they
are free for the one New Testament holy
day, the first day of the week.
Yeah, I I I I'm I'm picking up and I
picked this up when I was reading your
article as well because again, at least
in my thinking, I could be wrong on
this, but it seems to be that that the
real
driver here is the fact that you
mentioned there's a definite article
regarding the day. Mhm. It's not just a
day. Yeah. It's the day. So then it
comes down to what is that day? Right.
That's right. And so yeah, the first
argument being the strongest parallel
for the day with a person who
knows he can eat all things is that it
would be a distinctly new covenant holy
day that sets an individual free from an
otherwise long list of Old Testament
holy days. The second reason why we
would have to conclude that the day is
the first days
the Lord's day as opposed to the seventh
day Sabbath is because Paul explicitly
in other contexts states that no
believer should be under any negative
judgment from another believer for not
keeping a Sabbath, a new moon, or an
annual festival. And of course that's
Colossians 2:16.
Um and he says something similar in
Galatians 4:10.
So if if Paul is saying that it's not
characteristic of the strong to keep
Old Testament weekly, monthly, or annual
holy days, then the strong in this
passage who esteems the day
must be esteeming a different day from
any of the those Old Testament holy days
and that only leaves the New Testament
first day of the week on which we find
people worshipping. So does that second
argument make enough sense?
It does and it kind of segues us
perfectly into the next question if you
are ready for that. Well, I'm going to
go through all the reasons why it's got
to be the first day first and I hate you
know I just I got to do it.
Well, that is the next Well, that is the
next question. Yeah. That's that's
essentially the next question cuz on
page 29
Yes.
you write that quote several factors
require that the day in Romans 14:6 is a
shorthand reference to the first day.
That's right.
given a couple of the reasons or
arguments why continue in on this why it
is the first day. Right. Okay, so we we
carry on.
Yet another factor that would lead us in
in that direction is that the only
the only day on which we have Paul
expressly
calling any congregation to carry out an
act of worship is the first day. In 1
Corinthians 16:2, we have Paul saying
exactly that to set aside alms in the
first day of the week. I realize there's
a whole lot of you know seventh day
debate as to what that means, but the
bottom line is that the association of a
holy day with a setting aside alms from
the Old Testament is strong. Um you
would you would give tithes
and however you parse out the tithe as a
poor tithe, tithe given, you know,
to the priesthood, you name it.
The times of collection for that that we
have in the Bible are in holy days. And
and therefore the only day where we have
Paul expressly in his own epistles
calling for an act of worship is the
first day of the week.
Um a fourth reason is that the only day
in the New Testament on which we find
Paul expressly
gathering to break bread with believers
only for believers, not for the purposes
or or even
and preaching, you know, so breaking
bread and preaching is the first day of
the week. Of course in Acts chapter
20:7-12.
Um and it's a whole day, you know, spent
in in these acts of public and private
worship as at least as as it's described
in Acts chapter 20.
Um
you know, the next reasons that I'll
throw out there, you know, the fifth is
is that, you know, just before our our
verses in chapter 14,
we have a reference to the day without
qualification in chapter 13 where Paul
says let us behave properly as in the
day not, you know, in carousing and
drunkenness. And here the day is being
used metaphorically. It's like as as
those who who dwell in the resurrection,
who dwell in the light perpetually as
opposed to those who carry on in deeds
of darkness and day is being contrasted
with night. But you ask, you know, in
that reference the day has a particular
reference to walking in newness of life.
It it evokes a
recollection of the resurrection it
itself and the newness of life that
we're supposed to walk in that Paul's
been talking about since Romans chapter
6.
But you would ask if there's any echo of
the day mentioned, you know, just verses
before in chapter 14:6.
Presumably the day that um it's kind of
resounding in the background is is the
day of resurrection which of course
would associate best with the first day.
You know, yet another reason, we'll call
it a sixth reason
is that in Psalm 118:24, we have
prophetic anticipation of a new day.
This is the day that the Lord has made.
Um we all know that prophecy in Psalm
118:24. It's quoted numerous times in
the New Testament. In in
uh
you know, Peter's pivotal sermons in in
Acts, the passage is mentioned all
throughout the gospels it's mentioned.
But what is the new day that has been
made in Christ if not the day of
Christ's resurrection? And if there's
anything like an allusion when Paul
speaks of the day in 14:6 to an Old
Testament verse
Psalm 118:24 would be the strongest one.
And again, the reference there if to any
day at all is the new day inaugurated in
Christ's resurrection.
Um and then the last thing, you know,
the last argument is of course the one
that we've already made that the
strongest
explanation for minimalist and
maximalist perspectives on days is the
establishment of a new one.
And of course
the newly established day can't be the
one that the strong are disregarding
because it's the most important one.
It's the one associated with Christ's
resurrection. And so
for all of those reasons, the most
compelling conclusion is that in Romans
14:6, he who observes the day observes
it for the Lord is the strong party
being represented as someone who
observes one particular day above all
the rest. On that day he eats the full
gamut of foods that his new freedom in
Christ allows him to eat and he does it
alongside of and often in conjunction
with or following that central meal of
the Lord's Supper
by which the day is defined.
You mentioned Psalm 118.
Um and
I've heard this is the day that the Lord
has made. I've heard that said in all
sorts of contexts. Um and I think it's
important to point out that you
mentioned Peter's
inspired exposition Mhm.
of this prophetic Psalm. Right.
And Peter, the apostle, applies that to
the resurrection day.
Yeah.
So this new day has to be it's not just
every day 365 this is the day that the
Lord has made. Well, of course like he's
the sustainer of all things etc. But
there's something deeper going on there.
Right.
It's this is in conjunction with the
Psalter also talking about a new song
that we would sing. Yeah.
Eusebius brings this out in his
commentary on
uh Psalm 96, I believe it is a Psalm for
the for a song for for a new day or a
song for the Sabbath day. Yes.
Where you see this sort of um
synergism or or or or rather
synergizing of a new song and a new day
coming together. And he brings this out
in that this new day is the day where
the light came forth out of darkness.
And he kind of goes into talking about
how, you know, the old the the old
creation memorial was from evening to
evening starting in darkness, ending in
darkness, whereas this new day is the
dawn of the the first day, the light
breaking forth and coming through.
And so I think it's just important for
for people to note that this is the day
that the Lord has made is actually a
prophetic Psalm regarding uh a specific
day. It's not just necessarily generally
speaking about all days
generally speaking. Well, and one would
observe in the Psalm itself that phrase,
you know,
in verse 24, this is the day which the
Lord has made. I mean it follows very
specifically on the statement the stone
which the builders rejected has become
the chief cornerstone. That is one of
the most frequently cited prophecies
with respect to Christ's death and
resurrection.
The stone being Christ, his rejection
what took place in the events of the the
passion and really his whole ministry
and his becoming the chief cornerstone
this
foundation uh
is what occurs in the resurrection. It's
in that context that this verse is is is
brought to bear throughout the New
Testament. And so the concept that this
is the day which the Lord has made
should be associated with the
establishment of of that cornerstone as
chief and that having occurred in the
resurrection is is it's
by no means far-fetched far-fetched
exegesis. And again, the frequency with
which that passage is mentioned
throughout the New Testament um
definitely uh undergirds the concept
that its association is with the
resurrection. That's That's consistently
with what it's it's married to. And so
to take the next phrase, "This is the
day that the Lord has made." um
as it the establishment of a new day.
And especially given the pattern of
establishment of days on the basis of
monumental works in redemptive history,
um it's pretty natural conclusion to
draw. But what we have at the end of the
passage therefore is this picture. You
have a picture of two parties.
You have these strong minimalists who
understand that worship on the day is uh
is sufficient to fulfill their
worshipful obligation in the new
covenant. You have the weak who are
wavering. They're thinking that, you
know, some of these Old Testament holy
days are still binding, maybe all of
them in certain respects. And Paul says,
"Both can carry on fully convinced in
their own mind." How is he able to say
this? Because their convictions both
meet on the first day. They're going to
be one worshipping body together even if
some enclave of them are trying to keep
other days together. They can sing one
doxology together praising this
resurrected Christ mentioned at the
beginning of the epistle and all
throughout and expounded all throughout.
They can sing this doxology to God the
Father in the name of Christ together
because they have a common worship day.
Now it's important to note most
commentators have recognized Paul does
not mention this issue of days in Romans
14 as if it were of central
significance. He mentions it in passing
as if it were really already settled and
as if it pointed the way forward to
dealing with what appears to be at this
time a much more contentious dispute
over diet. Um and I want to mention just
before I talk about the diet issue and
how this relates.
I just wanted to mention how when one
embraces the sort of exegesis that I've
described how
once you embrace it it it actually
it answers several difficult questions
about the passage that the commentators
have poured over forever.
Um one difficult question is why does
Paul use the word esteem or judge to
describe these two parties? One esteems
one day above another. One esteems or
judges or um
it's something regards every day alike.
It's a perplexing question because Paul
almost never uses the word judge, krino
in the Greek,
in quite the way he does in these
verses. Here he's using it in what you
would call an approbative sense.
Um it's a judgment that implies a
positive evaluation of the thing being
judged. We don't tend to use judge that
way.
Um
we might in a court case say the judge
he he he judged for the plaintiff in in
which case it's like his judgment was
positive toward him. But normally when
we use the word judge it it usually has
a condemnatory sense. Like, you know,
when people today say, "Don't judge me."
They're not saying don't extend me a
positive evaluation. They're saying
don't
condemn me, right? Um but Paul in this
passage uses the word judge. Why does he
use the word judge?
To explain what I mean, he could have
just as well used a very different verb.
He could have used the the verb para
paratereo, which is what he uses in in
Galatians 4:10 to speak about a man
keeping one day as opposed to another
man keeping every day.
Why does he use the word esteems or
judges a day?
Well,
on the reading that I've supplied,
there's a natural answer for that.
Paul is getting at the fact that both
parties are making a critical judgments
about what their obligations are in
light of the gospel.
This really only comes out as a an
intelligible verb to use if we have
something like a minimalist maximalist
dispute underway
where something new has required you to
exercise wise judgment and insight. Um
in a way that if the apostles' preaching
was just a simple straightforward,
"There are no days at all."
it wouldn't require a sort of careful
judgment or insight to arrive at a
stronger faithful conclusion. But when
you take the position, the reading that
we've been advancing, it's intelligible
why Paul would use that particular
unique verb in that context. This
requires insight, says Paul. It requires
wise judgment in light of Christ and
what he's done. The second perplexing
thing about the passage for so many, one
might say, "Brant, if your view is
correct, why didn't Paul just come right
out and say uh one man um or rather the
one who worships on the first day of the
week
uh you know, or who observes the first
day observes it for the Lord." Why
didn't he come right out and say just
what
you're saying the day means? And you
have a natural answer for that.
Um
to say the first day of the week in
Greek is to say mia sabbatou or mia
sabbaton. It's It's It's to say
literally first of Sabbath, first of the
week.
Now if Paul is trying to make the
argument that it's mature and wise to
esteem one holy day above another, you
can understand why he didn't call them
holy days. To do so would be to weight
the conversation on the side of the
week. If these days still merit being
called holy, then why do we have to keep
them?
That's why Paul just says he esteems
a day above a day as opposed to making
that specific parameter holy day
explicit. He doesn't want to jump back
into the question of days, which is
largely settled. He's only bringing it
up to deal
with [clears throat] the matter of diet.
Just the same, he doesn't say the first
day of the week. He doesn't want to
mention the Sabbath, the very
uh you what you'd say catchall term for
all Old Testament holy days. If they
still are justly called the Sabbath,
then why aren't we keeping them? What
Paul wants to do is mention,
"We've gotten past this issue of days on
the ground that you all recognize
that he who observes the day observes it
for the Lord and that is enough when it
comes to our meeting together." Um even
if others want to worship on other days.
And he's going to use that as a
springboard to now talk about the issue
of diet and how there might be a
solution to that going forward.
Which perfectly segues us into that
final question that I want to ask you.
So on page 31, you write this.
Quote,
"The issue of days was intimately
related to that of diet because Lord's
Day observance included partaking of the
Lord's Supper and enjoying a community
meal.
You can see Acts 21 through 7, 1
Corinthians 5:7 through 8, 10:16 through
22, and 11:18 through 34.
Ironically, the strong wanted to feast
on all foods
on the day
while the weak wanted to celebrate all
feasts albeit with a more restrictive
diet.
In 14:6,
Paul explains why the principle of 14:5,
'Each must be fully convinced in his own
mind.'
applies to the issue of diet and not
just days.
Despite their differences, all parties
were united on
the day.
Romans 14:6.
At the Lord's Supper and community meal,
which occasioned dietary tensions.
Close quote. So my final question for
you in light of this,
why is the relation of days to diet
important in this text and why does it
actually help us pinpoint that the first
day is the new covenant Lord's Day?
Great questions, my friend. All right.
So
the
the answer to your question centers on
understanding uh a couple of things
about the Lord's Supper itself and the
uh ritual acts associated with that
meal.
Um
All throughout all the gospels emphasize
this that when the Lord's Supper is uh
first the Last Supper, we'll we'll start
there. When the Last Supper is performed
by Jesus, there are these four ritual
acts that you go through. You take,
break, give thanks, uh
and then distribute.
Uh the pattern is so strong in the New
Testament. You see these same the same
pattern in the feeding of the 4,000 and
the 5,000. You see the pattern
emphasized again when Jesus breaks bread
with the disciples on the road to
Emmaus, which of course is on the first
day and it is uh clearly a communion
meal that he's having in their midst. Um
but one of the things that you do in
those four acts is you give thanks. And
the the the Greek word that is used to
convey that is eucharist uh well, the
verb eucharisteo, um and from which we
get eucharist uh as a a name or a
description of the Lord's Supper.
When we understand that, it puts it in a
different light when Paul says, "He who
observes the day observes it for the
Lord." Now this is a truism. Everybody
agrees on this one. He observes the
first day observes it to the Lord. The
maximalist can look at their brother
who's a minimalist and say, "Well, he's
clearly at least observing the first day
to the Lord." The minimalist knows he's
doing that sufficiently for all holy day
observance. But the the phrase goes on,
"He observes the first day observes it
for the Lord, and he who eats does so
for the Lord,
for he gives thanks."
Now, this might make it sound like in
Paul's mind a general disposition of
thankfulness is a
the one thing that sanctifies all meals
and, you know, it's just Paul has a
premium on on gratitude
and that is what marks out every
Christian meal as just that, Christian.
I would submit that Paul something else
is going on here given the pregnant
allusion
of giving thanks to the Lord's Supper
itself, Paul is alluding to the fact
that the Lord's Supper, which all
regarded in common,
points us to strong dietary conclusions
that we are free to eat all foods. And
why would I say that?
When you take the Lord's Supper, Jesus
is is is setting before the disciples
these elements and calling them by the
name of his body and blood.
Now,
we all know that in the Old Covenant,
there was incredible
uh defilement imparted by coming into
contact with a dead body.
Um in fact, if you were to kind of make
a gradation of um you know,
it's what I'm looking for, um not stain
but uh contamination by unclean things.
Um the most contaminated you could be is
to be a leper.
But the closest thing to that is to come
into contact with a dead body. And and
when I speak of a gradation,
um
it as how contaminated you are, um you
would rank them based on
how many motions you have to go through
in that ritual system to go back to
being clean.
And again, the second most contaminated
status is that of having touched a dead
body.
Um it's noteworthy
that this is such a problem in the Old
Covenant that um
you actually have a different alternate
day set apart for those who were not
able in the time of Moses to keep the
Passover on the appropriate day due to
contamination with dead bodies. It was
so important to keep the Passover
and it was so problematic to come
anywhere near it if contaminated that a
whole different day in the next month is
set apart so that you could keep the law
and take that seriously that that
central holy day seriously in the Old
Testament. Well, when Jesus institutes a
meal and calls the elements my body and
blood,
um it's no surprise that in John the
offense was not lost on his his audience
when he says, "You must eat my flesh and
drink my blood."
Um the fact that the central Christian
meal,
when received with Thanksgiving, though
the elements are so described and have
such an association with Jesus' body
slain and bloodshed,
the fact that it is a holy meal marked
by Eucharistia, blessing, and
Thanksgiving
has to send shockwaves throughout a
Jewish community with respect to their
Old Testament dietary laws.
The central meal is, as it were, coming
into contact with a dead body.
And this speaks that if this meal is is
a blessing to us in Christ, Christ's
death has become a blessing to believers
who receive him in faith, then every
meal of any food can be received in
faith with a Thanksgiving spoken to
Christ.
And so what Paul is is suggesting here
is that the eating is yes, it's it's
it's um done unto the Lord on account of
his giving thanks to God. Um the strong
understand that that
Thanksgiving or Eucharistia can be
pronounced over their every meal because
it's pronounced over the most scandalous
meal.
Um the one associated with Jesus' death.
Um they they understand their freedom.
But the weak, on the other hand, they
refrain from eating other foods saying
the way to faithfully heed the Lord's
Supper, this holy meal, is to not get
into the business of eating other foods
that God has at one time said are
contaminating.
Now, is their mis- perspective mistaken?
Paul's going to go on all day long for
the rest of the chapter saying it is
mistaken. Verse 14, "I know and am
convinced in the Lord Jesus that nothing
is unclean in itself, but to him who
thinks anything to be unclean, to him it
is unclean." So he says, "The weak are
wrong."
But their non-eating is marked by the
same Eucharistia or Thanksgiving as was
their eating of the Lord's Supper.
They're trying to eat in consistency
with the holy meal as well. And though
they be wrong, you're all united on the
day, presumably where? At the holy meal.
And you both spend the rest of that day
either eating or not eating,
speaking the same sorts of Thanksgiving
that the Lord's Supper ought to evoke
from you.
And in that respect, you're united even
when your practice is different.
Man, there's so much there that
you mentioned the Road to Emmaus, the
meal.
And I'm just I don't know why I forget
this sometimes, maybe it's because I
have max capacity in my brain. And so,
you know, certain things can only take
like the forefront.
But it's like it's just that constant
reminder that nothing in scripture is
arbitrary.
No. Everything has like there's so much
of it it's like
it's not just being mentioned that on
the you know, on the way they had a
meal.
They ate a meal. Like no, this is being
mentioned for something very specific.
And so all of this to say, you know,
you've put out so many things tonight
that are just firing me up, too. It's
like after we get off of this, I just
want to go and just dig into my Bible
even more. Uh it just it's like it's
like furthered my hunger for the word of
God. It should. It should. And you know,
I'll just throw one more piece out there
about the meal. You know, that so many
interpreters after verse six,
it's as if Paul Paul has kind of lost
the script or he starts speaking in
incredible generalities in verse seven.
You know, Paul says for not one of us
lives for himself and not one of us dies
for himself and is
and there in their reading it's just
Paul speaking of, you know, Christians
you know, being deferential, Christians
being self-sacrificial for their
neighbor. All of that's there.
[snorts]
But if you see in the previous passage
eating with Thanksgiving, eating with
Eucharistia
as an allusion to the Lord's Supper, all
of this is more profound.
Uh for not one of us lives for himself
and not one of us dies for himself. Uh
for if we live, we live for the Lord, or
if we die, we die for the Lord.
Therefore, whether we live or die, we
are the Lord's.
If you think about the Lord's Supper in
the background, why is it that not one
of us lives for himself? Well, we just
all received the meal
where Christ says, "This is my body
given for you."
Not one of us dies for himself. Well,
because we're united with Christ, whose
death is also for you.
Uh for if we live, we live for the Lord,
if we die, we die for the Lord. This is
the ramification
of being gathered around a meal
where your savior dies and resurrects,
lives and dies for you.
And it's noteworthy
that this meal where we receive Christ
mystically, um
not [clears throat] by way of
consubstantiation, but
really and profoundly to our spiritual
benefit.
At this meal where we have this union
with Christ, um sig- signified and
sealed in such a powerful way,
there's this deep insight that follows
and Paul has it in verse eight,
"Therefore, whether we live or die, we
are the Lord's." Consider this.
Paul is saying that deceased dead
Christian brothers
belong to the body of Christ.
If our dead Christian brothers and dead
bodies in the Old Covenant were the most
contaminating thing you could imagine
beside being a leper, virtually being
dead,
if our Christian brothers are united
with Christ,
they received him in faith and partaking
of the Lord's Supper and are clothed
with him in baptism, and they're members
of his body,
how can any of the uncleanness laws
persist any longer?
The living resurrected Christ has dead
people as members of himself.
That verse might be one of the most
powerful statements that Old Testament
cleanliness code has gone away.
If the dead are part of Christ's body,
the resurrected one, the savior, how can
any other rule of uncleanness persist?
And he's going to go right in from there
to the fact that in fact, the strong
know they can eat all foods. They need
to make sure not to to cause their
brother to stumble, but
that blessing
with which our food is received, that
echo of the Lord's Supper, it it covers
all of our eating when we eat in faith.
Man, the richness of the text is just
there's just so many things that you're
putting out here that
you know, it's the these sort of things,
in my opinion, that should really inform
who has the most consistent exegesis of
the text. Like, what what did Paul
intend to communicate? That's what I
care about. I don't care about what do I
want to be there, what do I think is
there. I want to know what the apostle
intended to intended to communicate. And
you're you're really bringing out, just
to kind of wrap things up here, you're
really bringing out the the highlight
back to the question of diet and days,
the connection here, and you're really
highlighting the fact that um
the the connection there is that we have
something more going on here than just
general eating practices. You know,
you've mentioned food sacrificed to
idols, for example. Um
the Lord's Supper is actually in focus
here, and this I would argue is one of
the strongest connection points that we
can make in scripture to connect the
Lord's Day um being a new day from that
that came before, because we have a new
meal um that came before. And we talked
about this a little bit the last time
you were here, but just to really, you
know, clarify for the audience, you're
essentially saying, uh correct me if I'm
wrong, um that the the first day can be
um pinpointed here in this text because
what you're essentially highlighting is
that despite the various differences
that people may had, the command and
exhortation was when you come together
at the table, you do so despite these
differences, and that time to come
together to do that was at the uh the
first day.
That's right. I mean, and and what do we
find but you we already mentioned the
road to Emmaus. Uh when do we see Jesus
breaking bread in the presence of his
disciples? Uh it's on the first day in
the context of preaching and teaching in
a sermon, and what does it say but that
their eyes were opened to who Jesus was
at the eating of that meal. These are
all the connotations we would expect of
the Lord's Supper. Or you consider um
the only other time that we know for
certain uh that we have a meal and a
sermon preached together in the context
of believers uh fellowship in Acts 20.
Um the association of the Lord's Supper
with the first day is strong. And when
you have the passage beginning, "Except
the one who is weak in faith, namely the
person who only eats vegetables and
can't eat this larger, you know, a meal
of things,"
it implies the context of eating. And,
you know, throughout the New Testament,
we have, you know, these references to
love feasts, of course, in Jude. Um uh
and from what we can tell in 1
Corinthians 11, the Lord's Supper was
frequently attended by a much larger
meal, and that's why we had the whole
dispute in 1 Corinthians 11. Some people
were turning that into a much larger
meal and independent celebration feast
with just their friends in their
enclave. And he goes, "Look, that's not
how the Lord's Supper is supposed to be
done. Um it's great to have a church
potluck, you might say, uh in close
conjunction with the Lord's Supper in a
worship service, but he says, 'Look, if
you want to eat with your friends
exclusively, don't you have houses to go
home and do that at?'" Yeah. But the
idea that a larger celebration meal
would uh accompany the Lord's Supper um
from time to time when it was uh when it
was observed um is pretty evident
throughout the New Testament. And so,
the concept, then, that there is some
undisputed day of the week, or this
never could have arisen, and then what
undisputed day of the week would it be?
All the evidence points to it being the
first day. And what Paul is doing,
therefore, in verses uh 5 to 6 of of
Romans 14 is he's he's alluding to this.
We have two parties, maximalist and
minimalist, strong and weak, who are
able to carry on, both fully convinced
there in their own mind, with respect to
days. They figured out the first day is
going to be the focal point of Christian
fellowship because uh all of our
convictions, whether strong or weak,
meet there. And Paul is proceeding from
that place to say that just as one you
know, the one who observes the day
observes it for the Lord, the one who
does that exclusively does it for the
Lord, um just the same, that same
individual, when he eats, he does so for
the Lord. He gives thanks, echoes uh all
that we believe about the Lord's Supper
when he does that eating. Just the same,
the one who is weak, though he be
mistaken, he also echoes our conviction
that we have one holy meal that unites
us, and we have a blessing that proceeds
from it in every meal.
Um and in that respect, we can be that
one body he's united, Jew and Jew and
Greek alike,
so that we can do the very thing that
Paul says in Romans 15:6,
"With one accord, you may with one voice
glorify God and the God and Father of
our Lord Jesus Christ."
We can be that one body, that one voice
um in that context.
Mhm.
Brent, I really appreciate you sharing
some of your time with us. This has been
fantastic. Um I think your article does
a great job of showing that the
Christian practice of first-day
corporate worship is ultimately grounded
in the biblical text, not simply
tradition, which is the charge made by
the Seventh-day Adventist Church in this
context and many other Seventh-day
Sabbatarian groups. I really appreciated
your to the Greek grammar and that you
let that drive your understanding of the
text, which obviously is not novel to
yourself. Um I know your article is a
little bit weighty. Um it is a
scholastic work, and I appreciated that.
I had to read through it um a handful of
times because I'm not a scholar.
Um but I really appreciated your
fidelity to the text, your very high
view of scripture. And so, folks out
there that are curious about this, it
should be out in the coming months, so
you can keep your eyes peeled for that
in the Westminster Theological Journal.
Uh Brent, share any final thoughts that
you may have before we shut things down.
Yeah, you know, I mean, in the
concluding paragraph of the article, I
just I make the observation that you
know, when uh this particular exegesis
is embraced of of Romans 14, um
you know, you have the most continuity
and the fullest picture of uh of Pauline
worship in continuity with with 1
Corinthians. I mean, these are the two
longest Pauline epistles, as we all
know. Um but, you know, you would paint
this picture as a consistent Pauline
picture of Christian worship um
both in 1 Corinthians and in Romans,
you'd arrive at the conclusion that
believers enter a life of formal worship
via the the the right and sacrament of
baptism. So, Romans 6, uh 1 Corinthians
12:13, you know, by one uh spirit you're
baptized into one body.
Um
then you would get the idea that for
Paul, after this um you know, right of
entry,
believers continue um to present
themselves as a living sacrifice for the
rest of their Christian lives
in that they there's a a sort of focal
point to that um self-sacrifice and uh
offering of oneself in in corporate
worship as one body. I mean, you have
this emphasis that we are one body in
Romans 12 and 1 Corinthians 12 that you
know, there's an incredible um you know,
parallel between the two in listing
different spiritual gifts and offices in
the church.
Um but you'd get the idea as well, when
you embrace this exegesis, that this
sacrificial worship, done as a corporate
corporate body,
centers on the first day of the week. 1
Corinthians 16:2, that's when alms are
going to be set aside, surely an act of
sacrifice with which the Lord is well
pleased. And in Romans 14:6, we have the
day
where the minimalist, as well as the
maximalist, is is uh convinced that he
should observe it or keep it to the
Lord.
Um at the heart of their assembly in
both of the epistles, you'd have the
idea that the word of God being
proclaimed is
the main thing. You know, that's what
Paul wants to do in Romans 1:15 when he
comes to the Roman congregations. It's
the thing that is a centerpiece in uh 1
Corinthians uh 14. Um and the chief
gifts in the church that listed in 1
Corinthians 12, apostles, prophets,
teachers, are given to.
Um but the other indispensable aspects
of of worship that we would have would
be corporate prayer.
We've quoted 1 Corinthians uh
excuse me, Romans 15
uh 6 many times. You know, there's a
prayerful song and doxology uh that's
associated with worship, collection of
offerings, congregational singing uh
permeate this occasion in both epistles.
And we'd have the idea that on the same
day, the first day, um the Lord's Supper
would be a centerpiece where um the
formal blessing of of the the elements
is involved and the partakers of it in
the blessing and gratitude and
thanksgiving extended to God in the
course of worship would also take place.
And so, we just we have an incredible
continuity between the two.
And
I especially like the reference uh for
Romans 15:32 in this light, where Paul
expresses his hope to pass through Rome,
evidently on his way to Spain,
and to enjoy refreshment with them.
And of course, refreshment is a major
theme, uh you know, of the Sabbath going
back to Genesis
chapter 2, where God's God's resting um
isn't naturally understood as, you know,
mere, you know, sleeping. It it doesn't
make a great deal of sense.
Uh it's more as if God has just he has
built, you could say, his palace, and in
it he he delights and is refreshed. And
I think that Pauline reference, "I'd
like to come among you and be refreshed
given this portrait of worship
that was germane to Christians at the
time
would express the sort of refreshment
and restfulness that that one would look
for in what the Sabbath was of old, but
you might say doubly
refreshed in light of the good news as
it's explicitly proclaimed and
understood among Christians on the
Lord's day in the new covenant.
Amen and amen. Again, thank you brother
for being here and thank you the viewer
for also being here. May Christ richly
bless you in the grace and peace won by
him in his vicarious death on the cross
for sinners. Hallelujah and Maranatha.
Until next time, God bless.